it is the third week of Advent which
means it's the third episode of of
Christmas with me eart which also means
that we're going to read the third
Christmas sermon of our friend Meister
eart the Dominican Catholic Mystic and
philosopher I hope your uh last week has
been uh has been uh uh positive in some
way I I I I I'm very glad about the
response to both of the earlier videos I
hope you like the last one um at this
time we're going to go even deeper
sermon 3 is um it it it it continues
along the same lines there are a lot of
the same themes he goes a little deeper
into some questions such
as um this relationship between sort of
inner passivity and and active um sort
of how if we're supposed to be
completely passive and quiet and still
on the inside what does that say about
our outer actions our um performance of
of religious rituals and so on and so
he's going to say some things that you
know some of those think that he was
probably most controversial for which we
will get to in due
time
um oh right of course course we're going
to light the
candle the third candle for the third
week as you can see the first two are
already
lit there we
go for anyone
that um hasn't seen the early videos or
who don't know about me eart and his
ideas I suggest you go watch
particularly the first uh Epis episode
in this little series on Christmas uh on
Art's Christmas sermons or the full
video on eart and his philosophy again
and I'll put links to that probably in a
card up here and then maybe some links
in the description so we're not going to
we're not going to give an overview of
of his of his thought again um but we're
going to sort of continue where we left
off last week um what we can say very
briefly is uh that uh Christmas is eard
is primarily about the birth of the word
or the birth of the son which is
something that that takes place both in
time as the human Jesus was born but
also in the the the ground of the
soul and that's the theme that he's
going to continue building on in this
third sermon once again we are reading
from the complete mystical works of
master eart um translated by Maurice o
Conor
Walsh I think someone asked
um where these sermons are in this
particular work um some people reached
out saying that they have this book but
they don't know they don't know which of
all because this is a big book obviously
and there's a lot of sermons in here
they asked which of all these sermons
are the Christmas sermons and uh you're
in luck because the Christmas sermons
are the first four sermons in the book
so it's sermon 1 2 3 and four very
convenient
in any case sermon number
three Let's uh let's dive back into the
world of of eart and Christian
mysticism as will be the third sermon
here of of
eart again he begins with a Bible quote
and bases the entire thing on this Bible
quote which is Luke
2:49 I must be about my father's
business
he says this text is most appropriate to
what we have to say concerning the
Eternal birth which took place in time
and still happens daily in the innermost
part of the soul in her ground remote
from all adventitious
events in order to become aware of this
interior birth it is above all necessary
for man to be concerned with his
father's
business what are the father's
attributes power is ascribed to him more
than to the other two persons that is
more so power subcribed more so to the
father than to the son or the Holy
Spirit and so none assuredly can
experience or approach this birth
without a mighty
effort a man cannot attain to this birth
except by withdrawing his senses from
all things and that requires a mighty
effort to drive back the powers of the
soul and inhibit their
functioning this must be done with Force
without force it cannot be done as
Christ said the Kingdom of Heaven
suffers violence and the violence take
it by force so he's sort of summarizing
a lot of what he has said in the earlier
sermons here that um the one who wishes
to experience this birth of the Soul
needs to um as he says drive back the
powers of the
Soul um so it takes a lot of effort so
it's not just sitting there waiting for
something to happen it's it's an effort
of you know spiritual practice and and
and Devotion to God that leads one to
that state one has become unknowing
where there is nothing remaining into
which God can
um to which God can become apparent in a
direct unmediated sense a question
arises about this birth of which we have
spoken does it happen continuously or at
intervals when a man applies himself to
to it then exerts himself with all his
might to forget all things and be
conscious in this
alone now note the
explanation man has an active intellect
a passive intellect and a potential
intellect the active intellect is ever
ready to act whether it be in God or in
creatures for it exerts itself
rationally in creatures in the way of
ordering the creatures and brings them
back to their Source in raising itself
to the honor and glory of God all that
is in its power and its domain and hence
its name
active but when God undertakes the work
the Mind must remain
passive but potential intellect pays
regard to both to the activity of God
and the passivity of the Soul so that
this may be achieved as far as possible
in the one case there is activity where
the Mind does the work itself in the
other case there is passivity when God
undertakes the work and then the mind
mind should n must remain still and let
God
act now before this is begun by the mind
and completed by God the mind has a
provision of it a potential knowledge
that it can come to be thus this is the
meaning of potential intellect though it
often is neglected and never comes to
fruition but when the Mind strives with
all its might and with real sincerity
then God takes charge of the mind and
its work and then the Mind sees and
experiences God but since this enduring
and vision of God places an intolerable
strain on the mind while in its body God
accordingly withdraws at times from the
mind and that is why he said a little
while you shall see me and again a
little while you shall not see me we
talking here about the active intellect
the passive intellect and the potential
intellect and these are this is a
philosophical jargon particularly in the
the peretic school so the philosophical
School of Aristotle talks about active
intellect
passive intellect and so on we've
encountered these terms when we've
studied people like abolafia in Judaism
or it shows up in a lot of different
places Aristotle was very um influential
philosophically in in many ways of
course in the Middle Ages and you know
I'll be honest that um the relationship
between these intellects and what he's
saying here isn't always that um crystal
clear to me
um but I think what we can take away
from this for sure is is this um this
idea that he emphasizes that the the uh
the the intellect that is receptive to
God is the passive intellect so the
active intellect is that um part of
ourselves that sort of um and he will
get to this later on too that it's this
thing that takes information from the
outside and then sort of gives it to us
whereas the passive intellect is is that
which receives and so if we can shut off
our active intellect our individual
active intellect and let the passive
intellect our our passivity or receive
directly from God then that is um
preferable and then there's this uh
concept of the potential intellect here
which seems to be some sort
of and I'm honestly not entirely sure
how that fits into this wider picture it
seems to be he says the potential the
potential intellect pays regard to both
to the activity of God and the passivity
of the Soul so it seems to be some sort
of some part some part of the intellect
or some kind of intellect that that
knows
both uh at the same time in some way if
you guys have have any
better ideas of of of like more clear
ideas of what he's trying to say
especially with a potential intellect
then uh let's let's keep that discussion
going in the
comments in any case he continues by
saying when our Lord took his three
disciples with him up the mountain and
had shown them privately the
illumination of his body which he had
through Union with the godhead and which
we too shall have at the resurrection of
the body St Peter at once on seeing it
wish to remain there always indeed when
a man finds the good he cannot easily
part from it in so far as it is
good where this is recognized by
knowledge love must follow and memory
and all the powers of the soul and our
lord well knowing this is constrained to
hide at times for the soul is a simple
form of the body and wherever she turns
she turns as a whole where she always
conscious of the good which is God
immediately and without interruption she
would never be able to leave it to
influence the
body so um he's saying that um this
vision of God this complete vision of
God immediate without interruption to
the soul is so powerful that there is no
chance that the soul can ever be
concerned with anything else while it is
concerned or is or is experiencing that
presence of God and so God cannot be
experienced in that way at all times
because then we wouldn't be able to do
anything right we'll just be completely
absorbed in this in this presence of God
and that would sort of completely
inhibit any any powers any outward
actions um we be completely annihilated
in in a like a real sense just being
lost in that uh divine
presence thus it befell Paul if he had
remained for a hundred years at the spot
where he came to know the good he would
never have returned to the body he would
have forgotten it completely and so
because this is not conductive to this
life and alien to it God in his Mercy
veils it when he will and reveals it
when he will and when he knows like a
trustworthy physician that it is most
useful and helpful to you
this withdrawal is not yours but his who
does the work he can do it or not as he
will well knowing when it avails you
best it is in his hands to reveal or
conceal according as he knows you can
endure it for God is not a destroyer of
nature rather he perfects it and God
does this ever more and more the more
you are fitted for it so God chooses
when he gives this vision of of the
complete presence
and the amount
at least this is how how I read it the
amount that people are given this Vision
or this this experience of this presence
also depends on their own sort of
constitution where they're at in terms
of their
soul again going back to that idea that
it is something that we have to work for
right it's not just something that can
happen to anyone at any time
necessarily but you might say oh sir if
this requires a mind free of all images
and all works which lie in the powers by
their very nature then how about those
awkward works we must do sometimes works
of Charity which all take place without
such as teaching or comforting the needy
should people be deprived of this as our
Lord's disciples were so much occupied
with such things as according to St
Augustine St Paul was so burdened and
preoccupied with people's cares as if he
were their father shall we then be
deprived of this great good because we
are engaged in works of
Charity so a good question here asked by
either the audience or rhetorically by
eard
himself if the goal is to be completely
passive and just shut off all the
outward Powers all actions and all um
yeah these Powers as he calls them of
the Soul then what about all these
things that we that we that we are told
to do um by you know the the ideals of
the religion and even in in sort of
trying to mimic the life of Jesus and
and the disciples and the apostles for
example giving to charity helping the
needy being a good person you loving
your neighbor all these things how are
we supposed to do that if the goal of
this um um Annihilation is to completely
just shut off all outward powers that
seems sort of contradictory so he's
going to try to give an answer here now
note the answer to such
questions the one thing is noblest the
other very profitable Mary was praised
for choosing the best but Martha's life
was a very great profit for she served
Christ and his disciples Master Thomas
says the active life is better than the
contemplative in so far as in action one
pours out for love that which one has
gained in
contemplation it is actually the same
thing for we take only from the same
ground of contemplation and make it
fruitful in works and thus the object of
contemplation is achieved
though there is motion yet it is all one
it comes from one end which is God and
returns to the same as if I were to go
from one end of this house to the other
that would indeed be motion but only of
one and the same thus too in this
activity we remain in a state of
contemplation in God the one rests in
the other and perfects the other for
God's purpose in the union of
contemplation is fruitfulness in works
for in contemplation you serve yourself
alone but in works of Charity you serve
the many this is a very I think
important Point especially when we're
studying things like uh mysticism right
is that we always hear that that the
sort of goal for a Mystic and for you
know the goal of life is to be
annihilated and be United with God right
to
be you know to disappear from ourselves
and just be sort of absorbed in the
Divine Right um but for e here and for
many Mystics that's actually not the
goal that's a sort of penultimate step
on the goal because then if that's all
you do if you just become United with
God and then you stay there then what's
the point right then as he says here
then you serve yourself
alone rather the final step um after
this is
to come back from that experience or
sort of be in that be in that experience
but then return to your sort of
individuality in your your regular life
but with that contemplation in mind he
says here that contemplation and our
acts are sort of perfecting each other
so now your acts are according to that
inner contemplation of God and your
actual purpose the true goal of this
path thus
becomes uh those outward actions it's
serving the poor or giving to charity
and loving your neighbor that is
actually the goal but when you have um
annihilated yourself and become one with
God then you can do those things fully
in a sort of perfect way without any
sort of ego or or thought for yourself
it becomes all for for for God but but
through you know being for God it
becomes for for anyone else right it
becomes
a a
a practice of
Love rather than just being absorbed in
some uh Divine experience and I think
this is very common for people
to um today as well um that they become
sort of
um too enamored and and stuck in
this sometimes selfish idea of just you
know the
personal religious mystical experience
and eart as we have said eart is very
much against religious experience or
he's very he's critical of it at least
the the the big emphasis on these
experience because these experiences
first of
all in themselves don't really mean much
and also they they are they can be they
become selfish because they become the
thing that everyone's seeking rather
than to um use such experiences for
instance um to to be a better human
being in a practical sense that's the
actual goal we see this in in all of
these Traditions not all of them but
many of them um Sufism is similar right
we talk about f which is annihilation of
the self or the ego in God you realize
that there is only God that there is you
know this Unity but that is not the
again that's not the final step the
final step comes after which is Baka and
Baka means remaining or subsistence it's
when you return from that State of Union
to your individuality to the world of
Multiplicity you once again see all
things from seeing yourself as a person
and that as a tree and that as a candle
um through through being annihilated and
seeing everything is just one thing
everything is just God least according
to one interpretation then you return
and once again I am I and that's the
tree and that's the candle but now you
see all that from a completely different
perspective and then you can
act properly in response to that
knowledge of what is actually around you
and what the what reality actually
is in Hinduism there is theana and the
and bakti right and there are different
Traditions that emphasize different
aspects but in a sense you gain Jana or
knowledge of reality as it is so that
you are able to perform bakti
properly that's the sort of final step
is that loving worship that loving um
just that loving that
loving way of living informed by
knowledge of of reality as it is or of
God and again we see that also here in
Echo
C emphasizing that contemplation this
inner
experience presence of God is balanced
or perfected by outward actions in the
world he clarifies that even more here
by saying to this Christ admonishes Us
by his whole life and those of all his
Saints every one of whom he drove out
into the world to teach the multitude St
Paul said to Timothy beloved pre the
word did he mean the outward word that
beats the air surely not he meant the
inwardly born and yet hidden word that
lies secretly in the soul that was what
he B him preach aloud that it might be
made known to and might nourish the
Soul's Powers so that a man might give
himself out in all those aspects of
external life in which his fellow man
had need of it and that all of this
might be found in you to accomplish to
the best of your ability it must be
within you in thought in intellect and
in will and it must shine forth too in
your Deeds as Christ said let your light
shine forth before men he had in mind
those who care only for the
contemplative life and neglect the
practice of Charity which they say they
have no further need for having passed
that stage it was not these that Christ
meant when he said the seed fell on good
soil and yielded fruit 100 fold he meant
them when he said the tree that there is
no fruit shall be cut down so very
clearly here he emphasizes what we just
talked about right the person who you
know becomes one with God or you know
annihilates himself and has this great
mystical experience and then just stays
there
that's what Christ is referring to when
he says you know that the tree that
bears no fruit shall be cut down so
those people are like trees that bear no
fruit the fruits of all these
contemplative practices is the the
outward actions that we talked about
charity being at light so use the the
the the the imagery that's used in the
Bible here in in in in Matthew let your
light shine forth before men right to be
a light for others that is that is the
end goal that is the purpose and a
person who does not accomplish that who
doesn't realize that is like the tree
that bears no fruit and that shall be
cut down not literally of course but so
then he continues saying now you might
say but sir what are the silence you
told us so much about for this implies
images Galore Every Act must Accord with
its appropriate image whether the ACT is
internal or external whether I'm
teaching one or comforting another or
arranging this or that so what quiet can
I
get for if the Mind sees and formulates
and the will wills and memory holds fast
are not all these images so remember he
talked about the fact that we should
sort of forget all images that that
experience of God is beyond images so
this is what he's talking about here now
observe we spoke just now of an active
intellect and a passive intellect the
active intellect abstracts images from
outward things stripping them of matter
and of accidents and introduces them to
the passive intellect begetting their
mental image therein and the passive
intellect made pregnant by the active in
this way cherishes and knows these
things with Aid of the active intellect
even then the passive intellect cannot
keep on knowing these things unless the
active intellect illuminates them
aresh or illumines them fresh excuse me
so this is what we talked about earlier
right which I referred to very briefly
in my discussion about this intellect
now observe what the active intellect
does for the natural man that and far
more God does for one with Detachment he
takes away the active intellect from him
and installing himself instead he
himself undertakes makes all that the
active intellect ought to be
doing so again this is what I referred
to earlier right that the active
intellect is that which um takes in
external things and then gives that
information to the passive intellect
here the goal is to let God sort of take
away the individual active intellect and
put himself in its
dead indeed when a man is quite unpre
upied and the active intellect within
him is silent then God must take up the
work and must be the m master worksman
who begets himself in the passive
intellect see if it is not so the active
intellect cannot give what it has not
got and it cannot entertain two images
together it is first one and then the
other though the air and light show many
forms and color all at once you can only
observe them one after the other so too
does the active intellect which is
similar but when God acts in place of
the active intellect he engenders many
images together together in one point
for if God prompts you to do a good deed
at once all your powers profer
themselves for all good things your
whole mind at once tends to good in
general whatever good you can do takes
shape and presents itself to you
together in a Flash concentrated in a
single point surely this demonstrates
and proves that it is not the intellect
work for it has not the Perfection or
the resources for this rather it is the
work and the off off Spring of him who
has all images at once in
himself as Paul says I can do all things
in him who strengthens me in him I can
do not merely this or that but all
things in undivided Unity you must know
then that the images of these acts are
not yours neither are they from nature
they belong to the author of nature in
which he has implanted act and image so
do not lay claim to it for it is his not
yours
though conceived by you in time it is
begotten and given by God Beyond Time in
eternity beyond all
images so you might ask since my
intellect is divested of its natural
activity and no longer has any image or
action of its own where is its support
for it must always find lodgment
somewhere the powers always seek to
fasten on something and act on it
whether it be Memory intellect or
will and here comes a section that
is probably the most difficult section
we've encountered so far uh we're going
to try to get through it as best we
can the question is what is
the what is the
support of of of the
intellect when it is divested of of
natural activity right so when it
doesn't get any any information what
what it is it what what's actually
what's the basis of the intellect in
that case when it is Beyond these images
that's how I read
it now note the explanation of
this intellect object en largement is
Essence not accident but pure unmixed
being in
itself when the intellect discerns true
being it descends on it comes to rest on
it pronouncing its intellectual word
about the object it has seized on but so
long as the intellect does not find true
being and does not penetrate to the
ground so as to be able to say this is
this is it is such and not otherwise so
long does it remain in a condition of
questing and expectation it does not
settle down or rest but labors on
seeking expecting and rejecting and
though it may perhaps spend a year or
more investigating a natural truth to
see what it is it still has to work long
again to strip off what it is
not all this time it has nothing to go
by and makes no pronouncements at all as
long as it has not penetrated to the
ground of Truth with full
realization therefore the intellect
never rests in this life however much
God May reveal himself in this life yet
it is still as nothing to what he really
is though truth is there in the ground
it is yet veiled and concealed from the
intellect all this while the intellect
has no support to rest on in the way of
a changeless object it still does not
exist but goes on expecting and
preparing for something yet to become
known but so far hidden thus there is no
way man can know what God is but one
thing he does know what God is not um
the the the primary um characteristic of
apophaticism
apophatic theology negative theology we
can never know anything really about
what God is we can only know what he is
not he is
not ignorant he's not limited he's
not
um he's not finite he's not ugly you
know whatever we want we know that God
is surely is not these things but we can
never really say anything positively
about God we can't say that God is this
or that and this a man of intellect will
reject meanwhile the intellect finding
no real object to support it waits as
matter awaits form just as matter will
never rest until it is filled with all
forms so the intellect cannot rest
except in the essential truth that
Embraces all things only the essence
will satisfy it and this God withdraws
from it step by step in order to arouse
its Zeal and lure it on to seek and
grasp the true groundless good so that
it may be content with nothing but ever
clamor for the highest good of
all so I think we can connect this to
one of those things we talked about in
one of the other sermons this idea of
the intellect or the soul sort of um
where we wish to know something
uh we we're never really
satisfied right he's talking about this
here that the intellect is Never
Satisfied and can never rest in anything
really we talked about the idea that
it's a sort of Eternal wayfaring an
eternal thing the more you eat the the
hungrier you become when it comes to
these things and so that the only way
that the intellect here can become truly
satisfied is when it when it reaches
this
the groundless good reaches the
ground where it knows
nothing right so all these outer things
this is what I'm getting from this all
these outer things all these things that
intellect can know it it never satisfies
the intellect It's never
enough right and even when it comes to
knowing god we cannot we can never know
God as he says we can only know what God
is Not and so by un sort of this is
again apophaticism it's the principle of
AP aism removing all these things that
God is not until there's basically
nothing
left so this this is sort of
intellectual principle of this more
General U thing that he's saying is that
these things that we that the intellect
knows never satisfies it until it strips
itself of all knowledge and and
unknows then it can rest in the ground
because then it is found the
groundless good the ab grun the abyss of
the
ground again this section is pretty um
complicated I would say um but I think
this is at least related to what he's
saying here now you might say oh sir you
said so much about how all our faculties
should be quiet and now you go setting
up a great clamor of Yearning in this
quietness that would be a great moaning
and outcry for something we haven't got
and that would be the end of this peace
and quiet whether it were desire or
purpose or praise or Thanksgiving or
whatever else the Mind might beet or
imagine it would not be perfect peace or
absolute
Stillness
um so he's talking about the idea that
we seek God as you know the intellect
seeks to sort of rest in in the ground
of of God but that according to this
question right
is is a great
clamor um so it goes against this idea
that that that that we are in this state
of Stillness and quietude if we are
Desiring to you know to this and that so
it seems to go against what eart was
saying earlier he
explains let me explain when you have
completely stripped yourself of your own
self and all things and every kind of
attachment and have transferred made
over and abandoned yourself to God in
utter faith and perfect love then
whatever is born in you or touches you
within or without joyful or sorrowful
sour or sweet that is no longer yours it
is all together your Gods to whom you
have abandoned yourself tell me whom
does the spoken word belong to to the
speaker or the hearer though it falls to
the hearer it really belongs to the
speaker who gave it birth here's an
example the sun casts its light into the
air the air receives the light and gives
it to the Earth thus enabling us to
distinguish different colors now though
the light is formally in the air
essentially it is in the Sun the light
actually comes from the sun where it
originates and not in the
air it is received by the air which
passes it on to anything that is
receptive to light it is just the same
with the soul God Bears the word in the
soul and the Soul conceives it and
passes it on to her powers in varied
guys now as desire now as good intent
now as Charity now as Gra attitude or
however it may affect you it is all his
and not yours at all what God thus does
you must accept all that as his and not
as your own just as it is written the
Holy Ghost makes intercession with
countless Mighty size he prays within us
not we ourselves St Paul says no man can
say Lord Jesus Christ but in the Holy
Ghost he's clarifying that we still even
when we reach this Union or this
Unknowing when
we um annihilate ourselves and sort of
God we realize this birth of of of the
Sun in this case
um we still act in the world so that's
the sort of theme of this whole sermon I
would say right this relationship
between the contemplative life and the
active life we're still active in the
world we're not just sitting you know in
meditation completely obsorb in God all
the time we're still acting we still
have you know desires we're still we
still want to feed the the hungry we
still want to you know all these things
we still live our lives but we live our
lives in accordance with the will of God
as we said in the first sermon I think
our will becomes God's will so God we
realize that everything belongs to him
even our own actions in a certain sense
he's really the one that's acting all
these things that that are that come
from within you they actually come from
God so there's this realization that
every everything actually comes from God
everything is God in a certain
sense um so so that means that the
person now
acts um I wouldn't say perfectly well I
guess in a certain sense he acts
perfectly because he's acting and and
living his life in accordance with that
Divine will because everything at least
he's realized that everything is coming
from God and he's sort of in tune with
that that is that is my reading of
this this above all else is needful you
must lay claim to nothing let go of
yourself and let God act with you and in
you as he will this word is his this
birth is his in fact every single thing
that you are for you have abandoned self
and have gone out of your Soul's powers
and their activities and your personal
nature therefore God must enter into
your being and Powers because you have
bereft yourself of all possessions and
become as a desert as it is written the
voice of one crying in the wilderness
let this eternal voice cry out in you as
it listeth and be as a desert in respect
to yourself and all
things I love this imagery that that eat
sometimes uses that you are to become a
desert sort of empty yourself become
completely empty right again that's a
recurring theme but I think the imagery
of of the desert is very powerful here
now you might say but sir what does a
man do to be be void as a desert in
respect of himself and all things should
a man wait all the time for God to work
and do nothing himself or should he do
something in the meantime like praying
or reading or some other good occupation
such as listening to
sermons or studying scripture since such
a man is not supposed to take anything
in from without but only from within
from his God does he not miss something
by not doing these things so I guess you
could call this a a different
formulation of the same question from
before
whereas here it's more directed at sort
of
religious actions rather than sort of
well you could argue that that's
religious actions too giving to the poor
Etc but here it's more related to the
religious rituals like studying
scripture listening to sermons and so on
so it's a sort of different flavor of
the same
question eard says now listen all
outward Works were established and
ordained to direct the outer man to God
and to train him to speak Spiritual
Living and Good Deeds that he might not
stray into ineptitudes to act as a curb
on his inclination to escape from self
to things outside so that when God would
work in him he might find him ready and
not have to draw him back from things
alien and gross for the greater the
Delight in outward things the harder it
is to leave them the stronger the love
the sharper the pain when it comes to
parting um there's a section here it
says um um to act as a curb on its
inclination to escape from self to
things outside here whereas before he's
talking about an sort of getting rid of
the self here he seems to use the self
in a more positive sense as maybe he's
talking about more as sort of your true
self because he says
um he's SP speaking negatively of these
aspect of of of us that these
inclinations that try to escape from
self to things outside and in this case
the things outside are the are the
negative things right um whereas the
self is the is the good aspect and so
the only way I can sort of make sense of
this is that
he's here talking about the sort of true
self the self the ground where the self
is one with
God see then all works and Pious
practices praying reading singing vigils
fasting Penance or whatever discipline
it may be these were invented to catch a
man and restrain him from things alien
and
ungodly thus when a man realizes that
God's spirit is not working in him and
that the inner man is forsaken by God it
is very important for the outer man to
practice these virtues and especially
such as are the most feasible useful and
necessary for him not however from
selfish attachment but so that respect
for truth preserving him from being
attracted and led astray by what is
gross he may stay close to God and so
that God may find him near at hand when
he chooses to return and act in his soul
without having to seek for a
field so basically saying that all these
outer aspect of religion such as prayer
and and fasting and VI vigils and uh
Penance and all these things they're all
very important and he's sort of talking
about the purpose of these things it is
to to to keep your ego in check
basically right it's to not let the ego
and the mind stray into being too
occupied with these worldly temporary
things and to stay focused on the in the
in the inward things the true things
um at least for a lay person to just
keep those two in Balance to not get to
absorbed into to to the world um and to
not forget about the divine
um to keep that balance and for someone
who's very dedicated like a monk who's
you know in this sort of tradition maybe
um the emphasis is even more on the
other side of completely forgetting the
outward um so so he's pointing out here
that these actions these rituals these
practices are very
important um they're an important step
on the way and they're important for
people to to keep this ego in check but
then and this is where it gets really
interesting um where he
says but if a man knows himself to be
well trained in true
inwardness then let him boldly drop all
outward disciplines even those he's
bound to and from which neither Pope nor
Bishop can release
him from the vows a man has made to God
none can release him but they can be
turned into something else for every vow
is a contract with God but if a man has
taken solemn vows of such things as
prayer fasting or pilgrimage if he then
enters some order he's released from
them for in the order he is vowed to
goodness as a whole and to God
himself now here this
is possibly if not the then certainly
one of the most
controversial aspects of E's thought you
might think that you know and and as
some of you may know he was accused of
heresy
uh by the end of his life and certain
statements that he made were deemed
heretical he as a person was never
deemed a heretic but
certain quotes and ideas that he has
expressed were deemed heretical and you
might think that the the you know if
you're used to sort of a
mainstream contemporary Christianity
Today you might think that those ideas
that were deemed heretical were things
like you know this idea of Union with
God or that God's ground and the ground
of the soul is one and ground all these
things but that would be like the big
most controversial things it's not at
all actually um it's very different
things that that the that the church was
concerned with and this was one of the
primary ones he seems to say that a
person who in his words knows himself to
be well trained in true inwardness so
the person who sort of has really
penetrated into this ground and does
done these things that we've talked
about over these sermons then he can
drop all outward
disciplines and he seems to say so
pretty clearly here even um even those
he's bound to and from which neither
Pope nor Bishop can release him that's
that's pretty radical
stuff U and again that's one of those
things that that people you know the
church didn't really appreciate and he
will Nuance this now it will become a
bit clear but still uh this is one of
the most I think radical things that
eard says um in all of his sermons or
writings and this is different from what
we talked about earlier um in the first
sermon where you know him and someone
like margari pet will say that when you
become one with God then you don't have
to um do all all these outward
things in that case it's more no you do
them but you do them not because you
have to but because you know your will
and God's will is one will and so you
just do them
naturally um this is that's living
without a why as he calls it this is
different here he seems to be very
clearly saying that you don't have to
perform those things at all so what's he
actually saying here he continues and so
I say the same here whatever a man's
vows to manifold things by entering into
true inwardness he's released from them
as long as his inwardness lasts be it a
week a month or a year none of this time
is lost by the monk or none for God who
has captured and imprisoned them must
answer for it on returning to himself a
man should perform his vows for the time
present but as for what you might think
you have neglected in the preceding time
you need not bother to make it up for
God himself will make it up from the
period during which he calls you to be
Idol you should not wish to make it up
by any Act of creatures for the least
Act of God outweighs all the works of
creatures
so a bit more Nuance here right so it
seems like he's talking about someone
who's in the state of contemplation
currently whether that lasts for an hour
or a day or a week or a month or
whatever time that may be it's a limited
amount of time in that state he doesn't
have to perform these actions so it's
not like he's saying oh you've come to
this point of of spiritual enlightenment
so now you don't have to do these
rituals ever in your life that's not
what he's saying right he's saying
during this um
experience during this period of deep
contemplation which is never permanent
he said in the beginning that if if if
it was permanent
then um you'll be lost in it
completely but for that time you don't
have to bother with all these
practices whereas when you come
back you should of course start praying
again or fasting or whatever do your the
things that you have taken a vow to
do but he also points out that in at
that point you don't need to sort
of make up for what you for the time you
lost so so still it's pretty it's pretty
radical still but maybe not as radical
as it seemed a few sentences
ago this is said to learned and
illumined people I've have been taught
and illumined by God and
scripture but how is it with a simple
lay man who knows and understands
nothing but corporeal discipline and who
has taken on some vow whether of prayer
or the like to him I say this if he
finds it hampering and that he draws
nearer to God without it let him boldly
give it up for any work that brings you
nearer to God in God's Embrace is the
best that is what Paul meant when he
said when wholeness comes the partial
vanishes there is a big difference
between a vow taken before a priest and
vows taken in Simplicity to God himself
if a man vows anything to God it is with
the laudable intention of binding
himself thus to God which at the time a
man thinks to be for the best but if he
learns of a better way then knowing by
experience that it is better let him be
quite free of the first and
content also very interesting and could
be seen as pretty radical here right
talking about lay people and saying
similar things about
them perhaps even more radical because
this sort of
time um this time limit that we seem to
see before isn't really present in this
statement so um let me know maybe in the
comments what you think that he's like
is he being as radical here as as it
seems in any case he continues this is
easy to prove for one should consider
the fruits and the inward truth rather
than the outward act as Paul says the
letter that is all outward practices
kills but the spirit gives life that is
an inward realization of Truth you
should take good note of this and follow
above all whatever benefits you the best
for this your spirit should be elevated
not downcast but rather Ardent and yet
in a detached quiet Stillness no need to
tell God what you need or desire he
already knows real mic drop of of of a
quote
there Christ said to his disciples do
not use many words in your prayers like
the Pharisees for they think to be heard
with much speaking that we may here so
seek this peace and inward silence that
the Eternal Word may be spoken within us
and understood and that we may become
one therewith may the father help us and
that word and the spirit of both
amen we uh got through
the third sermon um to me that one is
certainly the most difficult so far it
has certain sections that are more dense
philosophically um but still contains
some real gems and some real good um
quotes and and teachings from from the
old Dominican
frer um this is one of those where I
think sometimes i' like I said I'm even
confused myself I'm not entirely sure I
try to to give some running commentary
as to sort of what I how I read things
and my interpretations and perspectives
and what I get out of of what's being
said here but I would of course love to
hear if you have um other perspectives
if you see something here that I'm
missing or whatever um I would love to
to see um what you have to say about
that so please leave a comment if you
have anything to add and let me know
also what you thought of the
sermon
um that
was three out of four so we only have
one more sermon to go we're going to do
that one on Christmas Eve or maybe
Christmas day we'll see either CHR on
Christmas we'll do the fourth one and
I'm very much looking forward to that
this has been a a wonderful little uh
thing this year so far and I I I'm
really glad to see that many of you out
there are enjoying it as much as I
am um spending some time with eart uh
during the Christmas season really gives
it um more
weight in in a certain sense which I
think is very
uh very
valuable so thank you so much for tuning
in for watching this third installment
of Christmas with master
ehart um I hope again that the holiday
season is treating you well I hope your
next week will be meaningful and and
positive and and uh bring you Joy or or
comfort in some
way and uh I look forward to spending
some more time with you next week on
Christmas as will be the fourth sermon
so I don't think there's really anything
more to say at this moment I'll see you
in the comments and I will see you in
the next
video
[Music]